good morning good morning good morning
good morning everyone happy Wednesday
super excited to be here with you guys
again welcome to gratitude during a live
stream number 18 we get together every
weekday morning pretty much at 9am to
share three things that were great
before because when you are grateful for
what you have around you you're much
more likely to be a happier and
entrepreneur and we need happy
entrepreneurs if you want to go out and
make a big impact on the world so I
start by sharing three things you guys
leave it in the chat those are you
watching live if you're watching after
leave it down in the comments below it's
important it's important that its daily
that it's consistent that you follow
through that you don't just do it once a
week or once a month to tell yourself
you're going to do it never never
actually take action it's daily and
consistent and you actually feel it
you've got to actually feel it the words
that you say have to actually touch you
here and it comes from asking why when
you list the three things that you're
grateful for just ask yourself why are
you grateful for that so you can feel it
a little bit in your heart if you want
the benefits you have to feel it
emotionally so coffee so i'm going to
share going to start with my three you
guys share it up in the chat and i'll
read through and get some shout outs and
a couple minutes and then again you guys
watching afterwards leave in the
comments below and and do it do it stop
just watching and actually do the
exercise you're going to feel better I
promise you okay for me number one I'm
grateful for my Toronto Blue Jays we had
a crazy game last night we were in the
wild card playoffs and we won in extra
innings Edwin Encarnacion hitting the
home run tool to walk off and give us
the victory so super excited the city is
pumped I was watching it with Nina and
that Nina was little relaxed watching it
I was freaking out it's oozy to run I'm
like off the couch bouncing around
but super grateful for for the joy
energy and vibrancy and everything that
it's brought to the city and to me Rock
image a's cap today the second thing I'm
grateful for is a good one for my son
Hayden yesterday he gave me this sticker
the Bow Wow sticker Bow Wow go do some
Wow today you guys um I just love his
his his fun his creativity his
willingness to try things his not caring
what people think his energy and
enthusiasm and I love it I love it every
time every time we're together it's
always lots of fun and smiles so I'm
glad the sticker stayed on for
everything trying to like cover it while
washing and all that so managed to keep
it on and I'm super grateful for that
and number three for me it's video day
it's Wednesday guys i'm pumped i get to
go to the studio today Jonathan salsa
and film all the videos for the youtube
channel for the week and so Wednesday's
always one of my favorite days of the
week I'm going to channel you guys it's
fun Jason's coming in my my video guy
and we're gonna we're going to pump out
20-something videos in a couple hours
and i'm excited i'm excited so let's get
to what you guys are grateful for leave
it in the live chat let me scroll to the
top j reyez let us off what are you
grateful for i love that he beat me to
the punch he is grateful for the
opportunity to help for clear focused
leaders and empire builders for talented
people who are genius at what they do
for life and delivering so many dreams
and desires to us all i love that i'm
going to try today instead of the mouse
i'm going to try hitting the keys to
scroll because i always end up scrolling
way too much with this youtube live chat
miha ville i would like to see you guys
and laying together oh we had a whole
bunch of League of Legends chat before
we took some action here good morning
everyone and rishi cook TV couple
believe i love it what else we got miss
Aviles hashtag grateful for the hustle I
love that much is hashtagging words i
love that Kim hello mr. Evan in your
believe nation how is everyone doing we
are rocking it what do you creep before
Kim leave it below your future builder
good morning grateful for fruit nature's
healthy candy make me hug you man I want
to go get a banana or something out what
else what else what else what else just
do it do it you guys are all doing to do
it Kim what exercise Kim leave three
things you gave before that's the
exercise put it in the comments que el
bien I'm grateful for my roof for
keeping me drive throughout all of
Hurricane Matthew I love that and stay
safe stay safe dan you're amazing evyn
keep up the good work you're amazing
today you're amazing that something to
then go find that genius level talent
and apply it much I'm grateful for the
rain which helped blow me back to sleep
after Adela woke me up at 1am that's
funny I can't sleep with rain so I'm
glad that it's working for you it's
awesome Rishi I'm river for the birds
they are truly so happy it's pretty cute
birds are pretty happy too i'm grateful
for the trees and three grateful for
amazing great movies amazing and great
together rishi loves her movies i love
it what else what else what else what
else what do we get before bunch of
chatter chatter jasmine I'm for my
family I'm grateful for my amazing
friends aretha for transitions through
life embracing the unknown I love that a
lot of people are too afraid to do that
so good on you Jasmine see it's a
YouTube thing I just press down and it
skipped all the way to the bottom again
okay now you're back up this it only
happens once per session Danielle
morning i'm grateful for resources like
you I appreciate that Danielle it's
awesome what else what else what else
Jackie good morning checking
in welcome Jackie Sarah good morning I'm
grateful today for my neighbor she's
awesome that's good having good
neighbors is seriously underrated man
it's so good so important to have good
neighbors I remember growing up having
awesome neighbors you know what now my
in my condo even over my neighbors are
I've never seen them with two neighbors
on each side I've never seen you do them
one I don't know if they even live there
there's this piece of paper that's like
some notice from the condo that's just
sitting on the floor I don't know I
don't think they ever come by I don't
know so as good I'm glad you have
awesome neighbors wrinkle for getting a
jumpstart for my car this morning well I
hope you made it in ok grateful for
being grateful to be grateful for being
grateful to be able to feel gratitude I
like it I like it mmm what's this 20
thing did I say 20 I don't know what I
said I don't know where the 20 thing
he's going up Adrian so grateful to be
present for this today also for fall and
new opportunities Thank You Evan and
beautiful community I love it and it's
true we do have a pretty special
beautiful community there was a guy who
made a video and I wanted to comment on
it just make it a buy my book I wanted
to say thank you for the book and I want
to leave a comment on to say thank you
and comments were disabled and he said
he disabled comments because he gets too
many haters and too many trolls and he
said he loves our community and doesn't
know how we built it just you got to be
involved in and you gotta hustle but I
agreeing that we have a pretty special
thing here on YouTube that isn't that
that isn't so common Adrian so grateful
to be oh we just read that one much I'm
grateful for my own form of meditation
I'm curious what that own form of
meditation is interesting Scott great
before 6am runs I feel alive and
powerful if you find something that
makes you alive and powerful do that
more Jackie I'm grateful for my
ungrateful for who God is in my life my
grandson Christian who turns seven
yesterday amazing happy birthday
Christian and for opportunity hidden is
my son Hayden is 72 there he is what
else what else sky's the limit oh nine
people for family for believe nation 11
people for life love it the relationship
bodyguard grateful for my new mindset
and positivity congrats on a new mindset
man every major ship that had and my
business in life has come from breaking
limiting beliefs and adopting a new
mindset so you got a new mindset you're
off to something exciting guys it's nine
ten that's it we're going to head off to
twitch we're going to play some League
of Legends while entering some business
questions if you're not joining us later
today then have an amazing day continue
to believe be grateful go crush today
and I will see you soon